want to make way for the popular Tim
Cowell show down this morning news
columnist ESPN around the horn
contributor and Tim kind enough to join
us Tim let me start with the elephant in
the room
or the red elephant the room with Andy
Dalton give me the strategy behind this
of bringing in Andrew Dalton as the
Cowboys back up why is he got to be the
red elephant no I I don't think I think
the strategy is fairly simple they've
done this sometimes bringing in a
veteran quarterback they haven't done it
a lot so that's what has people thinking
Oh what's what's this about they've been
very lucky dak Prescott started 64 games
he's he's really never come out of a
game while I was on the line his back at
the last two years Cooper rushed through
three passes in two seasons and here's
Andy Dalton floating around and he's
inexpensive and so I really think it's
it's injury protection now everybody
kind of jumps the gun and says well what
if dak you know doesn't come to camp or
something I really don't think I don't
think there's a single worry about that
honestly he's gonna make 31 million if
he doesn't get a long-term deal so I
really think it's just they've done a
better job getting backups and a lot of
spots and here's another one yeah I
didn't know if it was you know a shot at
dak Prescott or you know changes the
leverage here to me I just said you know
what it's a smart move to bring him in
he's from the Dallas area doesn't have
to uproot his family and given the fact
that you're not gonna be able to meet in
person you know he doesn't have to worry
about any of those things with the
coronavirus I just thought okay maybe
this is something good or something guys
have to have the mindset of wanting to
be a backup quarterback though Tim I
think Cam Newton to me is not a backup
quarterback because he won't allow
himself to do that
Andy Dalton is probably saying what do I
need to do alright I'll be a backup
quarterback and I think that's why I got
in this position here I think Andy dogs
made about 80 million dollars with his
time in Cincinnati you know where do the
playoffs four times never won a game but
he got the Bengals of the playoffs four
times that's something and he may think
of himself as I can still start for
somebody but I'm okay now at whatever he
is 32 I think
you know be in a backup this year and
you know if we have anything approaching
a normal season he'll play in preseason
games people will have tape on and
they'll seem surrounded by good
offensive talent including the line
running backs everything and see what he
and see what he looks like so I think
plus you know the fact he has a house
here I mean who doesn't want to come to
Dallas Danny I'll go to Austin all right
I'll leave you I know yeah you know what
i'ma stay out of Texas there because
he's enough Dan Patrick to go around for
an entire state house is playing locally
that Andy Dalton's in town well I think
locally there is a there is at least a
mindset oh there's the leverage and
there are some you know because I'll say
this in Dallas fans historically they're
never on the players side when there's a
contract situation maybe on em inside
that would be about the only time after
they but they've been what a Super Bowl
but yet generally this is a city where
they sided the teams and now they just
see dak oh he must be greedy he won't
sign a long term deal so there is a
certain you know percentage of fans and
want to say okay Andy Dalton's gonna
compete with him anyway hmm I don't
think they're bringing him in here to
compete with that Prescott I think
they're fine playing him if something
happens to dak but I think mostly most
people realize hey it's just a good move
to cover your backside in case something
you know there's no guarantee jack is
gonna play every game forever
I was curious with the CD Lam draft pick
because you don't need CD Lam he's a
nice luxury to have because you already
were a team that outscored the
opposition by over a hundred points you
had a good passing attack here how
surprised were you that CD Lam was tops
on their on their list well given that I
did a mock draft they got to me at 17
and I picked CD lamb that Monday
and I kind of jokingly said I think it's
great to thank you thank you I think
it's great not only to add a good player
but you keep him from becoming a
Philadelphia Eagle four picks later that
might be some motivation to I didn't
think it would happen I thought they
would I thought they would take chase on
from LSU but I don't if you think he's a
a receiver who's gonna be really good
and these other defensive players are
like you're thinking okay they might be
pretty good this guy isn't gonna be good
why not have three of them
there are things with Cooper's contract
they could be done with him in two years
if they wanted to be so I think they
just said like let's just load up let's
go for 30 points a game yeah yeah it
feels like hey let's be the Kansas City
Chiefs in the NFC we saw this with the
greatest show on turf teams started to
try to emulate the Rams it's really hard
to do it but it seems like that's what
Jerry Jerry probably said hey why not
just add another guy to our four by 100
relay team and let's see if we can do
what Kansas City does I think everybody
thinks he's gonna be a talented receiver
in this league whether he's the best
receiver to a couple years or not I mean
I don't think people realize Michael
Gallup last half of last year at 650
yards Union playing like a 1300 yard
receiver so they have a lot of weapons
let's see let's see what they can do
with them he's Tim Couch on Dallas
Morning News columnist around the horn
star joining us on the program
the NFL's gonna release that schedule
looks like as scheduled this weekend how
surprised are you a little surprised
although I think it just goes in line
with other things they've done in terms
of we need to go ahead and if we have to
change things later we'll change them
but for now let's have free agency let's
have a draft and let's go ahead
people get unnaturally excited about the
NFL schedule yeah and then they love it
so let's give them one more thing we can
give them we don't know if it's going to
happen we have no clue if fans are going
to be in any of these games but for now
this is the plan and we'll adjust later
I don't think
Armitage I think and I think most people
recognize the NFL has no guarantees that
this is gonna come off but everybody can
be a little optimistic I guess did you
cross paths with the Bulls in the 90s
what do you think of this documentary
you know I think the documentary is very
good I I didn't I was a I was a Cowboys
beat writer the first half and the stars
be right here the second half and I
became a columnist in the summer of 98
and that's the last dance so I can't
actually is about two weeks after that
ended obviously I watched him a million
times Rodman came to town later even
though he was briefly a maverick but
he's always a maverick Tim yes he's
always gonna be a maverick but did they
do a documentary a true documentary on
the Cowboys of the 90s you know that's a
good point I mean there's been different
things that nothing this exhaustive
nothing with behind the scenes footage
which would be very dangerous with the
Cowboys boy but how good would that be
with those personalities with those egos
if you had that if there's footage yeah
that could be incriminating well statute
of limitations there but just this whole
friction between coach and owner
I'm in the Bulls had the owner and GM on
the same page but they didn't have the
coach and the owner on the same page you
had that with Dallas where Jerry and
Jimmy didn't get along the Bulls had to
Jerry's no owner and GM Cowboys had one
in those same jobs and he couldn't get
along ultimately very quickly with with
the coach so there's a lot of there were
some parallels I mean success success as
hard as you know well Danny I just make
it look easy to me I just make but I
think if you start to look at you know
that the Warriors are interesting if you
did one of these with Durant involved in
it and draymond Green other than that
they're not an interesting team they
play an interesting style I started to
think about if you were gonna do this in
other sports like what would be the one
team in the modern era where you go now
that would be fun
oh that's good yeah you're right the
Warriors off the court would and I don't
think the Patriots I don't know if there
would be enough infighting certainly
seems like there wasn't at least until
the end so maybe if you could get some
of that it's hard you really you really
do have to go back to the Cowboys in the
90s say hey this was a great team but
off the field look at what the hell
happened
who else would ever have had win
back-to-back Super Bowls and then the
coach doubt I knew that just I would
never happened anywhere else and then
Barry Switzer gets credit for it's like
Jon Gruden gets credit for Tony Dungy
Super Bowl in Tampa but Jon Gruden beat
his own team well he knew all they
didn't change the audibles there I love
that Rich Gannon like Jon knew every
call that they were making there well
you know what Shaq and Kobe the Lakers
would have been that would've been
interesting yeah that would have been
some but it was really those two and
then Phil's job of sort of a lifeguard
in the deep end yeah and then genie boss
in his relationship with Jeanie buss and
you could get something on there what do
you got planned today well this is over
not a lot damn I am gonna write a column
that's not true I'll do I'll do three
hours of local radio we will talk to
Andy Dalton why do you why do you have a
collared shirt on you know I like to
dress for breakfast around here damn
it's hands-on you know john mcenroe
appreciates it when i get dressed up so
do you have pants on I'll give you $100
I'll give you $100 if you stand up those
here pooja
the nice flannel look look hot you look
hot
yeah oh yeah hey let's do this again I
mean I'm around here for if you need I'm
here I you know I put up a light for you
I don't know if you can tell is that
what that is
yes PM light see if I leave this way
there's I see it I see the reflection
there no no hey you look you made [ __ ]
makes you look really good your eyes are
popping everything yeah they are well
good luck today
thank you Tim hey he just froze he just
turned off his light there
thank you Tim